in the opening scene we see an ongoing
interview featuring Andrew cancade the
CEO of a rapidly expanding video game
company called Sentinel during the
interview Andrew expresses his
perspective on the Second Amendment
contending that gun ownership in the
United States is an outdated and unsafe
tradition to tackle this issue he
proposes a unique Solution by channeling
violent tendencies into video games he
claims that if someone wants to shoot
and kill people they can play Sentinels
video game or literally any other video
game elsewhere the chief security
officer at Sentinel named Orson Creed
watches the interview with his wife Abby
the interviewer questions Andrew about
orson's efforts to involve Sentinel in
military contracts Andrew mentions that
the two of them have contrasting views
he also reveals that Orson has attempted
to exploit his intellectual property
many times however Andrew assures that
he won't let this happen anymore this
causes Orson to get tense but his wife
comforts him by saying that she loves
him because he is not like Andrew
following this the couple prepare to
leave for somewhere when a group of
armed forces break into their place and
take Abby hostage in a self-defense move
Orson tries to pull out a knife but he
is quickly knocked out the scene then
cuts to a delivery guy who delivers a
package to a young man named Max it
appears that Max is a skilled video game
champion who works as a beta tester for
Sentinel the delivered package contains
the latest game which Max is set to test
as he inserts the game into his computer
he receives a call from a female
Sentinel tech support worker despite
having never seen her in real life Max
seems to have developed strong feelings
for her over years evident by the fact
that he regards her as Princess before
diving into the game princess informs
him that this game differs significantly
from other open World Games as it
focuses on providing an authentic
experience for gamers back at orson's
messed up house the armed gangsters led
by by Zane arene fixing a small device
on orson's neck once done they activate
it and leave the place with Abby as Max
starts the game Orson simultaneously
regains his Consciousness Max is
initially perplexed as the game has no
menus no options and no loading unlike
the other games however he disregards
these Oddities and tries to understand
what is going on he picks up a picture
in the game featuring Orson and his wife
leading him to discover that his in-game
character is none other than Orson
himself Max then explores the
character's virtual home and stumbles
upon a mobile phone in the kitchen upon
playing a video on it Zayn who is an NPC
in the game addresses him here it is
revealed that the events happening
within the game are actually being
reflected in the real world and that the
real Orson is being controlled by the
device on his neck Zay briefs Orson on a
series of missions giving him 90 minutes
to complete each task failure to do so
would result in Abby losing a part of
her body for each each uncompleted
objective his first mission is to sneak
into the national bank which is about to
be robbed and retrieve the contents of
safe deposit box 1121 Max is impressed
by The Realistic content of the game
unaware that it's actually synced to
real life dude they gave my avatar a
dick how Progressive he then stimulates
orison outside the house gets into a car
and drives towards the bank meanwhile
breaking news on television reports the
intrusion at the National Bank however
Max is unfazed by the the news as he
remains solely focused on the game his
in-game character arrives at the bank
and infiltrates it without detection
amidst of the robbery the controlled
orison crawls through the bank and comes
across an employee Max uses a button to
communicate with the woman directing his
character to inquire about the key to
safety deposit box 1121 in response the
lady directs him to her desk Orson
obtains the key and proceeds to the
designated box just before unlocking it
Max experiences a loss of signal for a
moment as ororon tries to remove the
device on his neck nevertheless the
connection is reestablished allowing him
to continue the game Mission inside the
safe deposit box he discovers a gun and
a note instructing him to kill the
robbers and take the money princess
warns him against harming the hostage
but Max dismisses her concerns
emphasizing that it is just a game
following this he takes down the robbers
one after another and successfully
retrieves the bags filled with money he
then loads them into the car and flees
the scene once at a safe distance Max
decides to take a lunch break but
realizes that he can't pause the game
leaving him puzzled seeking
clarification he questions princess who
offers to check on it as Max heads to
the kitchen he notices breaking news
about the recent national bank robbery
furthermore he is shocked when he
recognizes the same bank employee whom
he bumped into in the game this finally
makes him realize that the events in the
game are actually happening in real life
in a state of panic iic he hastily
attempts to call the police but the 911
operator tells him to remain seated and
continue playing the game Max then tells
princess everything but she also advises
him to keep playing undeterred he
proceeds to turn off the game but at the
same time zann shows up on the screen
the gangster threatens him to cooperate
or else he will kill princess and frame
him for robbing the bank at this point
Max learns that the money he stole in
the game has been deposited into his
real account and that Zayn's henchmen
have now surrounded his house left with
no choice Max reluctantly continues
playing the game for his second mission
Zayn instructs him to proceed to a
nearby private school and protect the
shooter who wants to carry out a
massacre there at this point the writer
thinks he's being topical but he's
actually toned deaf at first max is
reluctant to do this but he is forced
when Princess says that she doesn't want
to die he then stimulates ORS into the
school and incapacitates the school
guards reluctantly letting the shooter
kill the students this brings tears to
Max's eyes but he is helpless after this
Zayn proceeds to assign him with the
third mission but at the same time an
idea strikes Max's head he hangs up on
zann and dials his own phone number
ignoring princess's objections Max
speaks to Orson and tells him about
everything that's going on on the other
hand Abby whose face is disfigured by
the earlier confrontation is kept at
Andrew's Mansion she is currently
sitting at a dining table with Andrew
through their conversation we learn that
they have a history together Andrew asks
if Orson knows about their relationship
to which she angrily responds that there
was nothing between them just then zanen
walks in to alert Andrew about Max's
action however the CEO doesn't seem to
be much worried about it meanwhile Max
directs ORS into his home neutralizes
Zayn's patrolling guards and brings
himself inside the whole incident is
instantly reflected in the game and Max
is now able to see himself realizing
oron cannot speak Max implores princess
to unblock his speech frequency which
she reluctantly agrees to Orson finally
speaks up and tells Max that his house
is bugged Max initially doesn't believe
him so he shows all the hidden cameras
and listening devices in his house that
Andrew uses to keep an eye on him he
further reveals that he created every
security protocol for Sentinel including
bugging after debugging all of these
devices Max and oron sit and talk about
Sentinel during this Orson discloses
that he was the one who created the
technology that connects people to video
game characters which he refers to as
control X although he designed it for
surveillance he later realized that it
was better suited for the military
according to orison control X is about
making stronger Soldiers with fast
reflexes and two sets of eyes he created
it with the intention of saving people
but Andrew is using it for his personal
gain in the course of their conversation
Max notices the device on his neck and
or asks him to remove it however Max
appears to have something else in his
mind as he steps out of the house and
drags one of the unconscious henchmen
inside shortly after he removes the
device from orson's neck and fits it on
the henchmen which is still unknown to
Andrew now that orison is finally free
he heads to confront Andrew at Sentinel
and save his wife in the meantime Andrew
makes a video call with Max it Shing a
threat to harm his girl if he refuses
compliance in order to demonstrate his
power Andrew goes as as far as killing
one of his female employees frightened
Max reluctantly agrees to comply with
the instructions he is then assigned
with the third task to approach and
assassinate Caleb Angelo it turns out
that Caleb owns 51% of the world's
largest server file whereas Andrew only
owns 40% by eliminating Caleb Andrew
could easily acquire all the shares and
seize control over the world feeling
helpless Max directs his in-game
character to Caleb intercepts his car in
in the middle of the road and carries
out the assassination however Andrew who
is observing all of this becomes
suspicious when Caleb fails to recognize
Orson on the other front Orson arrives
at Sentinel only to be confronted by
Zayn and his henchmen at first he
intends to be on good terms but Zayn's
Reckless Behavior eventually makes him
lose his temper as a result of this he
starts fighting the guards and taking
down everyone who comes in his way
despite being a retired veteran he has
still got exceptional tactics in
fighting as he overpowers numbers of
guards alone he finally has a one-on-one
battle with Zayn and incapacitates him
as well Orson then makes his way to the
top floor where he finds Abby held
hostage by one of the guards Andrew
issues a threat demanding orson's
surrender or he'll face dire
consequences in addition he also
displays a video footage of his henchmen
holding Max at gunpoint as they delve
deeper in conversation Andrew expresses
his wish to control the world like a god
Orson asks for the reason why he killed
the innocent school children to which
Andrew reveals that they are the
casualties of War that's so [__] that is
so stupid he claims that sometimes to
make things better one needs to start by
making them worse he also asserts that
Orson could have been on his side but he
chose a different path Morrison argues
that he has no right to control people
but the latter remains dismissive
meanwhile at home Max despite being
under the threat of a gun covertly
stimulates his in-game character's home
before the gunman suspects the anomaly
Max's controlled character breaks into
the house and subdues him following this
Max gets in the car and drives towards
Sentinel in order to help Orson at
Sentinel Orson strategically signals his
wife at the right moment who then
attacks the guard behind him and throws
him off the roof simultaneously Orson
confronts Andrew in a physical brawl the
fight eventually gets intense when both
of them grab swords and begin a sword
fight Andrew turns out to be good with
swords as he manages to strike Orson
with several swings injuring him but
before he can finish off our hero Max
shows up with a gun and shoots him dead
swords don't have [__] on guns in the
final scene we see Max who is now
appointed as the new CEO of Sentinel
attending an interview in which he
pledges to bring the company back on the
right path on the other hand Orson who
is on a vacation with his wife watches
the interview with a smile on his face
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching